alright I'm here with Jung we're gonna
we're going to react to the trailer for
300 rise of an empire you guess they're
all back there a movie was a waste
because they survived it all and now
they're all back okay I don't know if
that's the plot of the movie you're
making this awkward as much is trailer
legendary look how cool that looks
horses hmm yeah yeah is it the same
actress yeah the one I got raped I'll
wind if I don't know everything
someone to justice this looks pretty
cool it looks it doesn't look like a
straight to DVD version of 300
I do wish girag buttons yeah check this
out they just always just gonna fall oh
but it's pretty dope mark this looks
like a good sequel like I thought was
gonna be like some straight-to-dvd yeah
like the action looks really cool
everything looks cool looking hell yeah
they make her badass now it's that
little girls
y'all got six-packs again hey packs I
guess that's nature are fun
yeah yeah direct and manage steal see
that oh shucks hell yeah dude this
really looks tie it up it's on IMAX I
hope it's good
Oh someone's gonna look really good you
know they don't see what that works
Justin it took a guy's Oh must be cool
I'm access said IMAX cool totally
watching I'm excellent
all right well young and I are in yeah
uh yeah I'll watch it yeah it looks
better than the other one I mean no it
doesn't I don't know why I said that it
looks like it could be a good follow
yeah I don't think it'll be topping the
other no no the other one was just epic
yeah and then this one is yeah that's
going to be cool I think that's this
would be cool movie entertaining